all right this is going to be a special
episode I think that the best episodes
we do are the ones where we highlight a
business or a person who is amazing that
you've never heard of and that's what
today's episode is the person that we
have on Jess ma she has built herself uh
I don't know 10 companies that have
combined you know they're worth $950
million she um and not only that just
has she made a bunch of money or been
successful with business but she's just
a force of nature uh people that I
respect think she's one of the best
entrepreneurs in the world and that's
kind of amazing for somebody who you
don't know her name you've never really
seen her do interviews uh you know Paul
Graham when when he met her and she was
at YC put her on the very short list of
a couple people with Sam Alman and a few
others as the most impressive people the
people that he thought 30 years from now
will have done done the most and gone
the furthest uh I was at a dinner that's
how I met her and a friend of mine
pointed out he goes that woman over
there is the best entrepreneur I've ever
met and he's lived in Silicon Valley for
15 years and to say that that's High
Praise uh so I had to have her on the
podcast to talk about everything from
her beginning where she was basically a
loser amongst loser losers in school she
talks about like you know Not only was
she not cool even in the computer Club
she got bullied and didn't really fit
into school didn't get good grades
really like was just kind of like School
wasn't for her she ended up dropping out
a high school because school wasn't for
her she but she started a business and
it started off as a very and you know
when she was a teenager she ended up
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
on this little server business that she
was creating just paying for her own
video games we talk about that all the
way to where she is today building these
biotech companies that are doing crazy
stuff uh and I asked her I was like were
you like a science genius like how did
you know to go with this how did you
have the confidence to go into a space
like that like I think we all I think
there's a part of all of us that wants
to go do the big bold crazy change the
world thing but we're afraid like who am
I to go do that at least that's a
thought had and uh it was kind of
amazing to hear her talk about she felt
the same way like she's like I got a C
minus in biology and now I have like a
nine figure you know hundred million do
plus bio company like that's crazy to do
that and and how she approached that how
did she meet these scientists how did
she get the funding how did she actually
talk herself into doing that from Rock
Bottom where she was completely
depressed and didn't know what she
wanted her to do with her life to now
you know living the kind of life she
wants the other thing that's in this
episode that I think you're going to
like is
she talks a lot about the
lifestyle and financial stuff that come
from people who are already really
successful so she know like I'm gonna
give you a trigger warning now uh she
talks about like you know yeah I just
like I hop on my jet like you know and I
bought this jet I bought it for this
reason here's the tax write off that I
got she's very open and very um clear
about this stuff and and I think for
some people who are at the very
beginning it's going to feel unrelatable
or it's going to feel like oh yeah you
know the the classic YouTube comment guy
who's like easy for you to say you're
already rich but I think the important
thing to figure out is she successful
because she always thinks this way she
she talks about her mindset and that's
why she was able to do this and also I
love when people talk about money stuff
I love when they're open and honest I
hate the billionaire who downplays it
and pretends like you know they're
flying coach and oh you know money's no
big deal and I oh you know I don't I
don't really do anything with my taxes
no I like to hear what people actually
do how they use money to improve their
life how they architect their businesses
she does that she's very open about it
so that's all in this episode I think
you're going to enjoy it uh this is an
episode with Jessica
[Music]
M all right it's good to see you good to
see you again um I want to tell people
the story of how we met which is not
like this extravagant story but it is
one that um I don't know it's like it's
this thing that happens that is like I
would have bet any anything that you're
an interesting person just on the way
that this meeting went so we got a
dinner together so that's like signal
one uh you know a a friend hosts a
dinner and it's like only friends
inviting friends to this thing that's
going to be like a you know some sort of
founder investor type of dinner so
already you got filter number one filter
number two is I'm sitting at one end of
the table you're sitting at the far end
of the of the table but our mutual
friend sea tells me he's like uh I was
like oh what's her name and he's like oh
yeah that's Jess ma he says uh and he's
like yes she is is um the most
impressive entrepreneur I've ever met
and I was like okay I didn't even ask
and he just says that and he's he G
basically gives you this extreme
compliment and I was like that's extreme
and he's like yeah she's extreme and I
was like okay I got to know more so
already I got a signal next thing I
noticed that you had your dog in the
restaurant and I was like okay that's
awesome love dogs dogs here and later I
was like is this like a service animal
because this is kind of like a nice
restaurant you were like yeah uh Amazon
you could buy this for $10 this vest and
like look and you flashed me like an FBI
badge that was like a um service dog
thing and I was like did you buy that
and you're like yeah this is great and I
was like wow this person is just you
know so there's all little signal
somebody who Rolls by their own little
rules my friend telling me that you're
you know one of the most baddass people
that he's ever met literally in the game
of Entrepreneurship and uh and then when
you did your intro you said something
you go so uh yeah I'm working on like I
started this thing in daero which I've
heard of and you were like you know it
started that and now i' I sit on the
board like you know whatever 10
companies and uh we do like bold science
bets and you didn't even explain it and
I was like okay well you have my
interest what's a bold science bet
you're like you know like curing cancer
but not like the typical way like this
other path to curing canc you like you
like kind of nonchalantly gave me some
answer as to what a bold science bet
would be and was like okay say no more I
need to meet this person I need to get
to know this person and I've gotten to
know you a little bit now and uh yeah
you are just that impressive so this is
my buildup um that is my perception and
tell me what that feels like to hear
because that's people never tell you
their actual perception first
impressions as they remember it uh you
know in their own head that's amazing it
was super fun to have that dinner and
meet you that night I just had a good
feeling that we were going to have a fun
time and normally I don't go out I'm
kind of like a loner like to be at home
and you know just take it easy after
work and uh you know it's a lot to deal
with with 10 companies we're g to add
more companies this next year and trying
to figure out like where do I want to
spend my time as an entrepreneur and
that's an ongoing question I'm sure
we'll talk about that but I've heard
about you um you know i' I've seen your
podcast and you're famous so it's kind
of an honor to get to be friends with
you too
so our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better well the
other thing that's cool is you have a
hold Co and like you know if I was going
to say what are some of the themes of
like almost like entrepreneurship trends
like there's fashion trends but now
there's entrepreneurship Trends one of
the entrepreneurship Trends is this hold
personal hold co- model but most people
are doing with the personal H call I
would say is kind of like small boy
stuff it's like we acquire this little
SAS app or like you know I'm GNA I'm
gonna buy this this Plumbing business
and I'm doing this hold code to roll
these up um and you kind of have a hold
code but you also have the big Venture
change the world kind of thing inside of
it which I find really fascinating so
you're like yes I'm doing a hold Co but
the hold Co is going to be all sort of
Game Changers type of like go big or go
home type of bets I find that really
interesting I also think that another
entrepreneurship trend is doing hard
stuff so I think Elon really popular you
know popularized like yeah you can
create the next kind of app and that's
cute but I'm gonna make rockets and
electric cars and then you know then you
have ai and Sam Alman and that's like
you know the kind of Cutting Edge
science do hard stuff movement and I
think you're a part of that too and so I
really like that you're here because you
represent you know some intersection of
these Trends and there's very few people
that really play that game and and uh
that's what I wanted to to learn from
you today is is why do you play that
game and how do you do it but let's give
people like I guess the quick background
um of you so can you give me kind of
like your how do you introduce yourself
when you're trying to brag a little bit
um about you know why anybody should pay
attention to what you have to
say I'll I'll be honest I'm really shy
and it's hard for me to talk about these
things because everyone I meet is so
impressed so no matter matter what I
feel like the dumbest person in the room
and the least successful person in the
room and um and so that's really hard
for me to talk about still but um just
to catch everyone up I'm an entrepreneur
I've started so many companies now my
first company was called indera and
inder is a financial SAS company we do
accounting tax billp management software
and services for businesses and our
customers were companies like slack
right Pinterest door Dash instart
coinbase
and I started that straight after
college I studied computer science at UC
Berkeley and when I was a senior at
Berkeley I was running in the computer
science club and uh I brought in these
speakers and uh one of the speakers I
brought in was this kid named Sam Altman
he was building a company called looped
and I'm like hey Sam what should I do
after college and he said oh you should
do IC and you helped review my
application and uh and then the rest is
history so I did that for 10 years screw
that to a few hundred people um
valuation and the hundreds of millions
of dollars but the way I built that
business was I didn't raise uh
traditional Venture funding so I didn't
bring in VC capital I only brought in
some Angel Investors I was able to
retain most of uh the ownership in the
company and uh and it's a cash flowing
you know profitable business to this day
so that was kind of my first uh forr in
a business and uh lots of ups and downs
and like you know being weeks away from
insolvency multiple times over and I
think it's because we were under
capitalized and I always ran things a
little too close to the edge there and
um and I was pretty public about that I
mean if you Google search me you'll see
that I've survived a bunch of near-death
experiences with that business and
eventually I I realized I didn't want to
be a CEO anymore I grew up with this
mindset of you have to be the operator
and if you're not the CEO and make a
company a unicorn you are a failure and
I just didn't that didn't land well with
me I I Google searched you know the
world's billionaires and I'm like how do
these people become billionaires and
most of them built companies a lot of
them were Diversified holding companies
and they held on to these companies for
decades and a lot of them they weren't
the CEO or the operator they were more
like investment manager and um I mean
Warren Buffett's a great example love
this um but there are many many more
like that and so that kind of got me
thinking H am I doing this wrong am I
just listening to Silicon Valley
rhetoric that's pointing me in the wrong
direction and um and then a few years
ago I went through a really tough
experience where U my boyfriend who I I
was living with uh died very
unexpectedly and I was going through
really dark period after that where I
was not able to work I just couldn't I
woke up in the morning and I be super
depressed and I didn't want to do
anything and I thought what would I do
if if um I was going to die this year if
this was my last year here because I'm
so depressed and I have to make myself
happy what would I do and running a
company was not on the list so I
immediately hired a CEO for Nero I had
another company that I had started that
I brought in a friend to run it's a
litigation fintech company and
um that company originates and funds
lawsuits so you know like the personal
injury uh Billboards you see on the side
of the road we do that in a very
sophisticated way um a lot of details I
I really would wish I could talk more
about but uh you know I don't want to
invite competition there and then I've
started a bunch of other interesting
businesses like that which also if you
go look at my website mwe.com I don't go
into much detail actually I don't
mention any of the detail on these
businesses for the same reason um I'd
rather build quietly and come up with
these really interesting ideas find
someone to go build those businesses and
a good chunk of them are businesses that
would just print cash but a lot of them
are more bold and that's why I got
interested in the biotech stuff I just
thought what would I do if I wasn't
scared of failure and after my boyfriend
died I thought a lot more about that I
thought like I shouldn't be scared of
trying and failing because I've seen
Rock Bottom I can't my life can't get
any worse than it is today so I might as
well try something you know and uh
that's that's where I landed with that
that's an amazing story and uh that
question of like what would I do if I
wasn't afraid of failing is like up
there in the pantheon of great questions
I asked myself that same question and it
change I wouldn't be doing this podcast
if it wasn't because I had three paths
that I had written out I remember I made
a figma file and I was like drawing like
a flowchart of my life
and I was like I could start a company
and maybe it'll be this maybe it'll be
this and that was like you said the
Silicon Valley rhetoric because what
gets written about is the Visionary CEO
founder who creates the next big thing
and that's the movies are about social
network and uh you know the the tech
crunch articles are about that the VCS
want you to be that because they're like
yeah it's sweet I get to write a check
and chill and like you go do the like
you go win the lottery and do all the
hard work at the same time like do the
low odds hardest thing you can do you
know over there so I was like I could go
start a company I could invest and just
kind of like be on the other side of
that that's I don't know if that would
be the most fun thing that I would do
and then I was like and I literally
wrote or I could be Tim Ferris and I was
like I think I want to be Tim Ferris I
was like well why don't I just do that
I've been thinking about this for like
seven years in the back of my mind and I
was like well because what if I'm not
what if it doesn't work then I'm just a
guy with a podcast it's cool to be Tim
Ferris it's not cool to be the guy with
a podcast like a podcast just normal
podcaster with 100 views or listens per
episode or something and I was like all
right so am I just gonna not do it
because I'm afraid that I might fail at
it like what's the worst I could have
and I kind of had this whole talk with
myself you know the most important talks
are not with mentors is the talks with
yourself and it sounds like you had one
of those too where you were like what
would I do if I if I wasn't afraid to
fail can you just talk a little bit more
about that talk with yourself because I
think everybody should have that some
version of that talk with themselves
yeah I I think just to expand on that a
big question I asked myself was also um
How Will I deal with the insecurity of
feeling like a beginner and terrible at
something despite the fact that for the
past 10 years I got pretty good at being
a CEO and running a business I'm sure
you felt the same way right where you're
a great entrepreneur and then now you're
getting into you know building content
and interviewing great folks and that's
the new skill set that you had to become
good at but for a while it's awkward and
like the I'm sure your first videos were
not nearly as good as the ones that you
posted over the past few months right
and so that's a lot of the self talk
it's like oh my God I didn't do a good
job I still don't know what I'm doing
people don't take me seriously do I even
take myself
seriously and meditating on that and
thinking you know what it doesn't matter
because I'm having a great time I'm
learning a lot and the outcome will work
itself out that's how I deal with it but
how about for you like what's what are
your other best practices yeah so being
a beginner uh and being okay like that
mental prep for yourself of I'm going to
be a beginner at this I think
is also a very important part of that
conversation I'm glad you said that
because it's one thing to just say um
what would I do if I wasn't afraid but
then like the fear is still going to be
there it's not just going to disappear
when you ask that question and the fear
is what the fear of being wrong being
failing looking dumb all those things
and so that beginner conversation is
important which is cool if I go into
this I'm going to start as a complete
beginner I'm going to get better at over
time because I'm good at learning and
I'll try and um you know if I don't need
to become the world expert at this but I
need to become competent at this and
that might take me six months to a year
that's like a reasonable expectation if
I really put my mind to this um it
reminds me of this story I've told on
the Pod before of Moy Ali who created
native deodorant and deodorant's not
curing cancer or whatever but it is uh
you know still it's a totally different
space and so when he told his friends
he's like I think I'm going to create a
deodorant brand and they were like cool
uh random you know do you do you even
wear deodorant like do you know anything
about deodorant and he's like today I
know nothing about deodorant but in six
months I'll know everything I need to
know about
deodorant and that idea of like writing
yourself a blank check I think is really
important to uh to starting anything and
you told me this when I was like dude
you're like working on crazy science
stuff I like that idea and I wish I
could do that but it feels above my
intellectual pay grade uh H are you just
a science genius and you were like no I
got like you were like I got like a c in
biology in school and then like you know
you're like I hired a tutor to like as
an adult to like learn about this and I
watched TED talks and podcasts and and
then I flew out and I met the scientists
and talked to them you just did all of
the like normal blocking and tackling I
feel with like just like uh is that how
you would describe it like that that was
totally different for me I just put you
on a pedestal I was like oh maybe she's
doing it because she's just smarter than
all of us and that's why she can do this
and nobody else
can no I still have major insecurities
about about this in fact last night I
dreamt again this is a recurring
nightmare where I am getting seas in
school and I am very close to flunking
and having to repeat a grade and I got
seized in by and also in biology when I
was high school so I thought I could do
a lot of things with my life but
anything related to biology is not one
of those things and then when I was um
so I was on the cover of ink magazine um
a bunch of years ago and uh there was a
woman who who was on the cover a month
before me her name's Elizabeth
Holmes and you know obviously we all
know what happened and so when she got
uh you know when thos went under and the
whole thing happened I thought Wow bio
really hard and I would be so paranoid
and scared of doing anything in biote
because I don't want to go to prison now
obviously you know there's more to the
story there and I don't think I'm going
to go to prison but like the thought
crossed my mind like should I even risk
my life and my career if everything's
okay like why do something hard and
where the last woman who tried to do
something here you know got you know
totally destroyed by the media and is
now prison like that's not a really good
inspiration for me to be try to be the
next Elizabeth Holmes but he didn't [__]
up as bad you know that's so that went
through my head and I had to overcome
that and then eventually I decided you
know what [__] it I want to give it a
try I'm want to you know just learn and
so I hired a biology tutor I like d
digested all the information and I
brought in people who've
been running biotech companies and who
had been part of uh big bio so that's
that's really how I operate it's just
bringing other people smarter than I am
another question I would want to ask you
and it's something I asked a lot of my
best friends is what would you do if you
were a
billionaire um and if you had like a
billion in hard cash in the bank
account and uh you were not allowed to
do what you're doing today how would you
devote your life and it's so fascinating
to hear the answer answers that that I I
get from my friends and I'd say
occasionally it's I I'm doing what I'm
doing today I would just keep on doing
that I I hear that from my more
successful friends but from people who
hadn't made it per se it's very thought
provoking that is a great question I can
tell a quick story and then I'm gonna
answer that question so the quick story
version is when we got acquired by
twitch I grabbed I was like first day
what do I want to do I was like let me
go find my people because I went into
this all of a sudden I'm in a company of
2,000 people who you know each are doing
their little function in this company
and I was like where my entrepreneurs at
like where are the people who like to
like you know make [__] happen and so
there was a company that had gotten
acquired a few years earlier and uh
three years earlier and they got bought
for like I don't know I want to say like
hundred million do and the founder was
one of the founders was still working
there and so I we go out to lunch and I
was like hey can we meet he's like yeah
let's go to the cafeteria I was like no
no I just need to leave this building
I'm having like big
claustrophobia they had to get out of
this building so we go to a lunch and I
say um why are you still here and he's
like oh what do you mean like it's going
great we're working on stuff I'm like
yeah but like uh you know is this what
you want to do like you're here you're
three years in and I'm looking in the
mirror thinking uh you know do I want to
be here in three years there's no way I
want to be here three four years from
now you're going on year four and uh
you're drinking this company Kool-Aid
what what happened to you why are you
still here and he was like you know
slightly offended but he was like uh no
it's great I'm having fun I'm learning a
bunch I go let me ask you the question
differently it sound it sounds like what
you're saying is you don't want to be
doing anything else right he goes yeah
and I go so let's say that I had put a
$100 million in your bank account
tomorrow would you show up to work and
he's like well no like I'd be I'm like
okay so you're doing it for the money
let's okay now we've established that
because if I all I did was I Chang the
money part of the equation and now your
answer is very different he's like well
I would buy a ranch and I would you know
I have for kids and we'd be outside all
day but then on the side I'd be building
this type of project I was like okay so
that's what you really want to do I'm
not saying you have to go do that but
let's at least be honest I didn't like
the part where you were telling me this
is exactly what I want to be doing with
my life
and I can say today there's things
there's a part of my life like this
podcast part of my life that is exactly
what I would be doing regardless of what
the number is in the bank account um and
there's a part of my life where like we
spin up companies but like we SP up
companies like for example we just spun
up a company that is I would say it is
opportunistic it's not the most fun sexy
company in the world I don't want to
operate it forever I'm like oh this
business will work it'll be successful
it'll have a great exit it'll provide a
great return it'll you know uh it'll put
you know millions of dollars in people's
bank accounts in the next three to five
years and that is good but if I was
totally post-economic there's no way I
would spend an ounce of my energy doing
that company like just the reality of
the situation so I'm like you know
partially following that that philosophy
but not all the way yet and I'm kind of
honest with my at least I'm honest with
myself of like yes and no but the my
answer to the question of if I was
totally post-economic you know I have
more money than I'll ever be able to
spend uh the thing that I would do is I
would teach and I would either just
teach in the way that I do today like
podcast write a book uh you know just
basically be curious go learn something
and then explain what I learned to
people who don't have the
12 hours to go down the bioelectricity
rabbit hole um you know you know but
that's what I would do or I would extend
that if I wanted to be a little more
ambitious and I would actually create a
campus and a school for people like me
and be like cool let me create the ideal
school that I wish I had when I was
younger and do that um I just don't know
how much I don't know how much that
would be fun like the kind of reward
versus extra effort that that takes
versus creating content online and doing
the same thing but not having any of the
like students and physical campus and
stuff that I need to deal with you we
should talk about that sometime because
I've thought about that as well I wish
there was a better school for me and for
people like us who are you know are
creative entrepreneurial quirky and the
traditional school system does not like
satisfy our needs um and what's cool
about it is you know if let's say we
came up with a concept for how we would
do this like I would just put my whole
team behind it and then we'll find a way
to find the money and then it will just
manifest like these things don't have to
wait until you have a billion dollars in
cash is the point and but I asked you
the question because I I found that bio
was on my list like oh I would do more
bio stuff I just fund it and like but I
know people who could fund it so I could
just call them and have them fund it and
I I don't need to fully fund it and I'll
manifest um and I think I think a lot of
us um have so many of these things that
we want to create in the world and it's
dangerous to eat
because life priorities change and I
think that I see this with many of my
friends to go on to get married have
kids they get comfortable they're
building their ridiculous house and then
life goes by and they never go through
this Liston it always stays a dream or
an aspiration and I I just couldn't
allow that to happen to myself and I'm
so glad that you're you know doing most
of the things on your
list that's a a great phrase it's
dangerous to wait um because I think
most people feel like it it'd be Ry to
go do it and I think they vastly
underestimate the risk of allowing
yourself to just wait on the things you
really want to do in life because
actually what happens is you acrew this
like um it's not like by waiting you get
closer to the goal by waiting you
actually get further away from the goal
because you add all this space that gets
filled up with other activities other
responsibilities thoughts you know uh
you train yourself to not take action on
the [__] you actually want and to like
go down this like long winding path I
remember when I was um back to when I
was working at twitch there's a guy Dan
who's now the CEO at the time he came in
as like I don't know Chief product
officer or something he was he became my
boss so we go into this like one-on-one
and um he's like so like what are your
like career you know what's your like
goals for yourself here you know at the
company and I was like um well I have
two options here I'm either going to lie
to this guy and say oh I can't wait to
get promoted from L7 to L8 to L10 like
you know like that's like the ladder
literally it's a ladder and you that's
your goals CL Ang goals I was like I'm
either going to lie about this to him
because he's you know he's my manager I
guess that's what I'm supposed to say or
I'll tell the truth and so I told him
the truth and I was like uh yeah I can't
wait to go build another thing or just
go on my own and like I don't see myself
being here and uh long term and he was
like okay well that but he didn't he
didn't I thought like that's going to
put him in an awkward position but he
was like you know he's an experienced
guy he toally you know rolled with it
he's like okay great uh now that I know
that and I was like you know I don't
want you to totally write me off because
I said that like I do think I'll be here
to earn out this part of the deal I
think I can do good work while I'm here
like you know I think you'll you'll get
value from somebody with my talents
being here um so I hope you don't just
like you know say oh this guy's not here
for the Long Haul like write me off but
that's the truth and he was like done I
appreciate that now let's talk about the
thing you really want to do what is it
that you really want to do and I was
like oh I want to do this this this but
you know before I do that I need to kind
of like you know I'm trying to get you
know save up you know enough Capital
because I'm gonna that's going to
require a lot of capital and I'm going
to learn some things I'm going to build
my network and and he's like yeah I'm
not really a fan of the like I want to
do X so I'm gonna go do a and C before I
do X he's like you're better off usually
just going ahead and trying to do X and
I was like all right you're right that's
true I don't need like you don't even
need to say anymore you're right I was
bullshitting myself a little bit um
thank you for saying that that's
actually a really Val Val piece of
wisdom and um it reminded me of um
there's this Tony Robbins Ted Talk have
you ever seen the one time Tony Robbins
went to Ted
yeah he's like on stage and he's like um
what stops you know I've been I spent my
whole life basically studying like what
stops people from having what they want
in life and he's like you know um what
do you think it is what holds you back
and people are like oh like you know
from whatever it is you want you want a
better relationship you want a better
career you want more money you want
better health whatever whatever it is
and people are like oh I I don't have
the time and other people like I don't
have the the knowledge the skills I
don't and the people in the crowd are
saying it and Al Gore is there and uh
this was like right after Al Gore had
lost uh the presidential race to Bush I
think there was like a runoff like they
had to recount the votes in Florida or
something and like they it went to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
ruled that whatever Bush won and so he
hears this voice that says I didn't have
enough Supreme Court Justices and he's
like what the hell what do you mean like
who's oh Al Gore's here and Tony Robbins
gives is this like one minute thing that
like actually kind of like bits slapped
all their answers he's like uh you know
everything you guys just said is a
resource you lacked money time Capital
Supreme Court Justices it's a a thing
you lack Supreme Court Justices yeah
that's the most hilarious
example he's like the only thing you
actually need is resourcefulness he's
like that is the master skill the
ability to go get the resources you need
when you need them for the thing you're
trying to manifest and he's like if is
it not true that if you are MO at enough
charismatic enough playful enough
convincing enough um you know like
determined enough and and Charming
enough can you not get everything that
you want like is it like is there really
anything that is outside of you if you
really put your all into acquiring that
resource could you not have gotten the
time the money the the network all of
those things like Al Gore if you were
not more passionate when you were on
that stage in that debate would it ever
ever even come down to that Supreme
Court Justices no right like you would
have just won in a landslide uh if you
had acquired the things that you
actually needed to get there and that's
kind of what you're saying of your
little manifestation studio type of
concept I love that because it's like
you are completely striking out from the
thought process of an entrepreneur
they're like do I have what it takes
either personally or financially or uh
you know knowledge and skill-wise you're
like well if I want to start a bio
company I'll go recruit the best bio
people and then I'll go raise the
funding
we say like you don't have enough time
or money those are always the excuses
but you create the time by hiring other
people to do the work who are better
experts at whatever that thing is and
you manufacture the money by raising the
money and in my case I've got a
multi-person investor relations team
they have connections to tons of
billionaires and family offices and
we're trying to like place these deals
with our family office connections and
that's going to be you know within the
next year that's going to be a
four-person team and a capability I had
so instead of creating a hold Co let's
create manifestation CES that's what I'm
talking about are not always G be right
I I mean you coined it it's the
manifestation code and uh because now if
it could be a profitable Endeavor great
sometimes it won't be and but the point
is all of us have that thing we want to
create in our our life and we want to
have the ability to do that in a way
that's painless fun
and exciting for us as the IB eater what
about like um you know crazy science
dreams you have you said you have ideas
or you're talking to scientists all the
time what are some things that are you
know in the future that you're excited
about that is not just a pipe dream like
there might actually be a pathway to do
it like you know I don't know if the the
grow test tube baby in a vat type of
thing like I don't know if that's like
just a dream or there's actually people
working on the that that might be
scientifically possible or practical can
you tell me about some parts of the
future that I should be excited about or
my kids might get to experience I
actually think that is very viable the
test two babies um I know of I've talked
to several scientists who are doing the
portion to like for example let's say
you wanted to be the mother of a child
not the father and we could take your
genetic material and create an egg out
of that I think that we're going to see
that within the next five
years and
than the converting you know having a
artificial embryo generated Avatar Style
that's a little harder to do I I met
scientists who've been able to um get to
maybe six weeks before the whole thing
falls apart and that will get better and
better over time um but the implications
there are huge like for women imagine
not having to deal with this and uh not
having to do egg
extraction um if you're you know if
you're having trouble conceiving and
then what's also realistic I think is
extending Our Lives by 30% I think we
need to be prepared to live till we're
120 or longer and right now theer liim
our head is oh I'll probably die when
I'm 90 we're not thinking about the
exponential rate of change here and I am
talking to a lot of longevity scientist
I'm seeing the data it's compelling I
think we're going to live longer and we
need a plan for that future
what's the short version of how we get
that extra 30% is it drugs is it uh diet
Lifestyle Changes is it reversing aging
is it you
know uh getting blood from Young uh you
know baby seals what what are we going
to do to to make that
happen it's probably going to be a
combination of multiple
factors and you all these projects fall
under what you call bold science can you
define bold science what does that mean
yeah there just so many uh companies
working on very
incremental uh you know companies where
it might extend your lifespan by 3
months or six months that's not a great
outcome like you're going to be going to
the hospital and taking chemo drugs for
another six months before you're dead
what do you do that's like I'd rather go
to go to hospice than prolong my
suffering but if you could instead
patching the problem like putting a
bandid on a gunshot wound is the analogy
um what if you could get to the root
cause and reverse cancer for example so
right now everything we do within cancer
is about um trying to kill the cancer
cells through chemo radiation surgery
carte therapies are super hot and
trendy but that just basically involves
using your immune system to Target and
kill your own cancer cells but what if
killing cancer is the wrong approach and
actually cancer happens because your
cells are trying to protect themselves
in some way and if you could train them
and Coach your cste of Killing Them
let's rehabilitate them get them to
integrate back in with their
surroundings then you could fix cancer
and so we're working on a company around
that um that's what I mean by buold
science that's that's uh that's great so
it's basically non non-incremental a big
leap in function or leap in quality of
life so like you know a a step complete
step change and usually that's going to
come from taking a different approach
than like you know uh or taking a
different point of view on the problem
looking at it through a different lens
and um you've you what you do is you
partner with Scientists to make that
happen one of the things you said that I
liked uh when we were talking before was
you're like I get on the plane I get on
the plane every time yeah and um I don't
know exactly what you mean by that but
talk about that because I think that's
just an
entrepreneurial as part of the
manifestation Studio you got to just get
on the plane sometimes what what do you
mean by that that I have a real example
I have uh there's the successful
entrepreneur who I'm sure you've heard
of um maybe you even interviewed him he
lives in Vegas I live in LA and I just
said hey tell me a time and place on
Sunday and Monday and I will fly to
Vegas and I will meet you I will
literally take my plane and fly there
just for the meeting and then fly home
afterwards and then Tuesday same thing I
have um Patrick hollison from stripe
asked me to hang out with him and have
dinner and it's like all right cool I'll
just get on my Jet and go see him and
then fly back and be back in my Ved
after dinner you know and does does that
only work if you have a jet no buy a
Southwest ticket I mean just get
creative about it I do it so often
though that it is really nice to have my
own airplane but like I think that um it
doesn't matter like if I have to fly to
London and see someone I will I gladly
know book a ticket and do that and uh I
think that it really you know I had
Delan Aire do this for me where he
literally flew in from South America and
he went straight from the airport to
dinner with
me and that was the first time I had a
one-on-one meeting with this
person and it really made an impression
on me I'm like wow this guy went out of
his way he was planning to go to some
other City instead he came to LA to meet
me just for
dinner and and he's more important than
I am by by a million miles he's so much
more important than I am that made me
want to be friends with this person and
um you know I have another billionaire
who I hit it off with we hung out for
drinks um we were part of a bigger group
and we had two hours where he just
talked about the meaning of life all of
his regrets all the things he do
different he's like this 70 something
year old dude and he's like yeah
everyone wants me for my money but no
one just asked me these questions that
you're asking me about life advice and
I'm like you know what we should
continue this where do you live I'll
visit you he says I live in the Bahamas
I'm like great I'm visiting you and we
booked the time I'm seeing him for
dinner in three weeks and I want to
literally go there just to see him and
he's so happy about it and I want to get
four hours of downloading this man's
Wisdom and uh it's it's super cool I
think it's massively underrated uh we uh
my uncle calls it meeting belly to belly
he's like you got to meet belly to belly
in business and he's in the real estate
game it's a totally different game but I
loved it I was like not face to face
we're going belly to belly and I just
think that that was like created such a
good visual in my head if you were going
to score it let's say if I gave you one
point of like trust productivity
relationship building for a zoom call
versus um meeting belly to belly if one
is if one is the is the call how much is
the in
person well um yeah I would think B the
other way I mean it's it's it's just
they're totally opposite ends of the
spectrum like a belly to belly like
flying out to see them is the ultimate
10 out of 10 way to engage with someone
there is no better way than to say I'm
flying five hours out of my way to see
you and I spend you know dinner with you
and a call is definitely a one and a
zoom call is maybe a two it's like
that's how wide the Delta is right and
uh oh the other thing I want to mention
is that even I think a lot of people
think oh but Jess like you you've
already like Meed a bit so of course
people want to hang out with you well I
was getting meetings like this when I
was 16 and I knew nothing I cold emailed
the retic guys I cold emailed Justin and
EMT from twitch I guess it was Justin.tv
back then and I said hey I'm this idiot
16-year-old I think you just put it on
the table like I'm an idiot and I think
you are brilliant and I'm willing to fly
to you and I just want to be a
um a fly on your shoulder and see you do
your work and just like you know just
follow you around for a
day and so if you pull up the Justin.tv
archives you will see me driving him
around San Francisco and going to a
poker game with him and like all this
random stuff just because I was Will to
do that Mark Benny off replied to me
also again I'm an idiot 16y old that's
amazing this is when you're a teenager
you also told me because I asked you
because um
I think one of the valuable things in
life is to study like to become a good
evaluator of people like if let's say
you're an NBA general manager you need
to be able to spot Talent um I think any
business person or investor needs to be
able to spot talent and ideally Spot the
Difference between good and great great
and the best in the world and um when I
met you I really felt like oh this might
be somebody who's one of those like
Elite best in the world at what they do
and they're going to do special things
that are Beyond even what really great
smart you you know intelligent people
are going to do just because they seem
to be operating differently but I need
to understand them a little more so I
asked you a question when I was getting
to know you and I was I was like if I
met you when you were younger like 13
years old what would I have seen and
would I would there have been any
signals for uh for this and I I said you
know and I will say on my side I was a
totally unimpressive 13-year-old you
know um you know there was no signals
that I was going to do anything out of
the ordinary um you know forget like
being great at something just like out
of the ordinary Beyond average and um so
I wasn't that way but I've met a lot of
people who were you know they're like
teenagers they were flipping things like
you know on eBay or they were building a
product of some kind or you know
whatever you have an amazing kind of
backstory uh can you tell it what were
you doing what was like your first you
know interesting little business you
were doing when you were you were a
teenager when I was 13 I started a
dedicated server and collocation
business business because that's what I
thought you did in high school that's
just I don't know why but I thought it
was kind of normal and I grew that set
about a few hundred grand in Revenue did
you know somebody else doing it why
would you think that's normal I don't
know I was the internet forums you know
there are lots of people who do this so
I thought okay this is like a commodity
business but I could probably figure out
how to do it and make a few bucks and
offset my gaming server expenses that
was the goal I just wanted to make like
$10,000 a year to offset my own costs
and buy some clothes and not have to
like go work at the shopping mall or
like Rak leaves or shovel stuff so
you're like I'm playing video games I
want to scratch my own itch be able to
play my own video games and and like you
know pay pay off that buy some clothes
were you cool in school were you like a
no smart popular kid or who were you
total geek loser I was so lame I so I
had no friends I went to the Computer
Club at my high school um which is all
the Nerds who also had no other friends
so you have to be friends with each
other they were making fun of me and
they were bullying me I was literally on
the bottom of the bottom TM
po like that's how I knew it was really
bad I'm like okay I have to get out of
here as soon as possible so I ended up
dropping out of high school uh halfway
through my sophomore year but I got into
this really cool college program called
Simon's Rock College you know Simon Rock
and going to college early it really
Saed me because I was born in high
school
I wasn't doing well I was I was getting
terrible geds because I was uninterested
and because I had no friends and I felt
like I couldn't relate to anyone all
other girls um and guys just like were
interested in things that I had no
interest in so when you said hey I would
love to create the school for people
like us I just thought holy cow I want
to create that school too we can make
this happen let's do it let's brainstorm
it let's set aside sometime another day
or let's just go meet up for dinner I'll
come wherever you want any day you want
I will I will fly to you and we will put
together you know a game plan for what
this would look like and how we would
Manifest this without having to wait
till we're you know sitting on a billion
in
cash yeah okay done I love it belly to
belly booked um you tell me about this
server business uh did you make the 10
grand off that I was making like hundred
of thousands of dollars a year off of it
I was making more money than my teacher
I remember in biology class it's 800
a.m. and I can't pay attention and I'm
like doing like the biology teacher
clearly doesn't like me cuz she knows
that I'm high potential but I wasn't
doing well because I was up till 3: in
the morning answering customer service
and sales emails so of course I only had
like five hours of sleep and when you're
13 and you're operating on five hours of
sleep you're not going to do well and
but to make myself feel better I thought
well at least I'm making more money than
my biology
teacher well I'm asleep moral Victory uh
so when you were meeting these people
because you were like I'm a I'm a dumb
16-year-old college kid you're College
because you're 16 because you dropped
out of high school yeah and like just
went to college um you met Justin Khan
you met Mark benof you met uh you know
these different YC Founders did you do
you learn did you learn anything they
stick with you was there a story that
like you remember uh like what did you
get out of those meetings yeah what I
got out of it was that holy cow there
are other people like me who are a
little crazy who are willing to approach
life and Entrepreneurship in an
unconventional way and who are willing
to do uh you know the hard things so
when I saw Justin and when I saw Steve
Huffman Reddit I I realized wow like I
don't need to wait till I'm older to
start doing this today and I also don't
need to have money I don't have to have
like a job to demonstrate success first
so it's more of the Mind mindset I would
say it's always mindset and psychology
more than tactics um when you're meeting
these people that I focus
on yeah yeah and you you also told me
you had met these other people like when
I was like oh what's
um uh I forgot I was like I think I was
asking you like what you do with your
money and you were like yeah I uh you
said one interesting thing you were like
you're like you know uh taxes um people
I think I was asking you something about
taxes and you were like people don't
spend enough time on taxes so can you
tell me um we'll put this in the bucket
of billionaire secrets uh you you said
you've met a bunch of successful super
rich people and the way they think is a
little bit different than the way
everybody else thinks and I'm interested
in that Gap what's different about the
way that the most successful the richest
people that you know think what is it
that they're thinking about differently
um one of the things was taxes but you
had a few more can you tell me the taxes
point and anything else you kind of
remember on that yeah top tax
optimization is a really big deal
because if you think about it if you're
spend it if if half your money is going
to Uncle Sam it's really going to impact
your compounding like do a you know
compound interest uh calculator and
you'll see the Delta is very wide if
you're starting at age say 30 and these
billionaires employ the best tax
strategists in the world So eventually I
said hey could you introduce me to your
tax person and that person of course
works with like 30 other billionaires
and has saved them you know collectively
hundred billion dollars in taxes and
then I I've gotten enough of these tax
professional intros where now I have a
whole collection of them I call and I
combine advice from multiple tax
professionals and merge it all together
and I think that's the next level most
people just pick one person they say oh
I've been working with Betty is my tax
accountant for the past 10 years well
Betty doesn't work with billionaires
it's time for a new tax accountant I
literally had this conver conversation
with someone over lunch last week and he
texted me right before we got on this
call saying oh my God like this is going
to make me millions of dollars more over
the next few years like well this is so
true uh I feel when I uh like I have
like a lawyer and a tax person and if I
feel like I if I talk to another tax
person or a lawyer I'm like kind of
cheating on them and it's like that's so
silly that's so dumb of a way to think
about it like first of all it's your job
to get the best opinion possible to get
the best answer the best answer is not
going to come necessarily from the one
person you know who you picked one time
five years ago without vetting anybody
else um they may also not specialize in
other stuff you're doing oh now you're
doing real estate deals well they don't
know anything about real estate deals or
you're doing uh you have an exit and m&a
they don't know anything about m&a so
you know you should be talking to people
who really understand that stuff um a
team though multiple opinions is better
than one uh Specialties matter um also
when you said that it reminded me I was
like oh yeah the person who I have doing
tax strategy stuff they they stopped
giving me strategy after year one like
we you know like the bulk if I had a pie
chart of 90% of the like strategy convos
convos we had were at the very beginning
and then like now I'm just like the
client that they you know stamp the the
thing on like every year right like that
happens naturally same thing with legal
legal stuff and so you kind of need to
keep dating in order to have like fresh
ideas or advice coming in uh from that
perspective exactly you also said like
there's a certain amount of time you
think people should spend on or like you
know maybe not should but like the math
tells you you should be spending a
certain amount of time on taxes and
actually the what people actually do is
maybe less than 1% of their time yeah
exactly less than 1% way less than even
0.1% because if taxes impact half your
income potentially if you invest just
even five or 10% of your time this year
to finding five amazing tax strategists
get all their advice and figure out how
to apply it 10% of your time
as the up upper bound here and you're
making like way more money as a result
it pays for itself like 100 fold it's
the highest IR investment you can make
and it's way better than like investing
in the stock market with the money
you're paying these tax people no that's
so true because your tax is always your
biggest expense uh and if you're a
business person you have your you know
your business tax then you have your
personal tax you have like investment
tax capital gains tax you have all kinds
of taxes every single year you know the
same dollar gets taxed a bunch of times
um so you're right basically it's the
biggest it's the big biggest expense
even 10% sounds absurd because I'm like
oh that's 36 days out of the year it's
Overkill you don't need that much time I
mean even five days in the year to do
this gets you a lot you're right on the
math like you would be justified
spending 36 days out of the year you
would be justified spending 10% of your
time and intellectual mind share on some
on your biggest expense that's going to
compound every year for the rest of your
life like of course that would make
sense so that is a kind of like aha
moment for me right what about like um
coaching or uh you know some sort of
like what is your like basically if the
studio the manifestation kind of like
vehicle here is an extension of you and
your brain and your dreams and your
desires and then like getting the brain
to be like functioning well seems
important do you do anything whether
it's therapy nutrition morning routine
like do you do anything like that to
like make sure you're the psych ology
that you know the the little voice in
your head is saying the right stuff yeah
for sure I have um I have two different
coaches I talk with each month and I
think of it as like going to the gym or
taking a shower even if I think I'm
happy or in a good mindset I need to
still go see them to make sure that my
head is screwed on
properly and yeah cost me a ton of money
but it pays for itself right away I also
have my CEO group I is it once a month
it's kind of like alcohol an Alcoholics
Anonymous for CEOs I'm in YPO young
president organization but there's also
entrepreneur organization and Fage list
goes on and on and they're yeah you
think oh I don't have time for it but I
actually think you don't have time not
to do
that that's a good way of putting it um
also help stuff we don't think about
that what if you could optimize through
better nutrition and neut tropics and
through IVs
you're not only your longevity but your
mental
acuity so I work with five coner doctors
to come up with my own custom plan and
I'm actually going to put something
together that I could share with all my
friends so anyone I love can get on the
same
program um and it includes the
supplements custom compounding my own
supplements into you know just two pills
um so it's a little easier um and then
doing the exom IBS once a quarter which
I'm I'm a huge fan of and I don't what
what is that what is that word you just
said what what are you doing exosome
IVs and uh yeah I mean so it's still the
science on it still a little um you know
up in the air so I just want to be you
know good on the disclosure there um so
it's not necessarily the Fountain of
eath but there's the belief that you
know if you're if you're doing if you're
bringing in stem cells you know through
an IV um it will help you uh lower your
biological age give you more energy and
help you with um with your autophagy so
basically your body's ability to get rid
of uh old and dying cells and if you do
that then the thought is you're going to
have more energy more energy means or
brain power more brain power means more
ability to manifest and create great
things in the
world and so this is another area where
let's say you were able to improve your
mental function and your energy by
25% by the way if you do all these
things you could probably do like better
than
25% is that worth $115,000 a year which
is roughly how much I spend on this
maybe I spend 20 or 25 Grand on it it's
not a lot of money you don't need to
pull a Brian Johnson where you're
spending a million dollar a year to get
80% of the results this is the 8020 rule
of Brian
Johnson uh yeah that's what I need uh
good I I'm going to hit you up for some
recommendations send you some referrals
and um and then yeah I I'll I'll
eventually pull us all this feedback to
make it so that we could share it
publicly and for free so you guys don't
necessarily need to pay for your own con
doctor to do this for you I think it's
ridiculous that like all the work I'm
doing here I'm spending this money on it
like this should be like a public
service that's offered yeah because it's
not so personalized to you basically
you're saying no it's not that
personalized 90% of what I'm doing like
anyone else should just be able to do on
their own it's just not this whole
longevity optimization arena is so new
and in order for other folks to monetize
on it has to feel bespoken unique to you
when so uh give me the quick rundown so
you spend this money you have this this
program that you're doing you said you
do this exosome IVs uh okay great what
are like if you were going to go from
like most impactful to like you know
whatever Fringe you know stuff what's
the most the most impactful stuff you're
doing again I'll be super honest it's
hard to know where the impact is um like
on just what you what you kind of
believe in or what you would recommend
to your cousin or your your your friend
who you you know who you're like look we
we get all the disclaimers you're not a
doctor this not the your this not you
know bulletproof science cool okay
amongst friends you kind tell what your
opinion is yeah uh I'm a friend of eeg1
I'm sure people have talked about that
on your pod before um I'm a fan of uh
adding in other there's this whole list
of supplements and neut Tropics that I
can't even recite the name of for you
but I could publish the list for you if
you'd like and then having them all
again put together in you know a few
compact pills that you could take um and
then have a friend and who does that you
you like go to a compounding pharmacy
and you're like hey can you make these
pills for me like cool we'll have like
32 pills delivered like how does that
work yeah I have a friend who actually
has his own so I get it at Cost but my
plan is to work with him to create it so
that he can make some profit and then my
friends will have basically what I take
and not have it be marked up too much
like all these other scumbag internet
companies are trying to
do shout out to the scumbags out there
keep keep doing your
thing that's it in a nutshell I know
that's isem I us on a hug fan of and
then there's
also um yeah I mean there a bunch of
peptides as well if you want to do the
more advanced thing um and on the
peptides you know some of them are
injectable um so you know that I would
consult a doctor on but the supplements
you you could probably just do right and
I would Benchmark I would take um the
true
Diagnostics um biological you know age
test just to see how you're doing before
middle and after and
um yeah so that's another so taxes
Health
um coaching and mindset what are the
other categories for you know
billionaire secrets we haven't covered
um I think those are the big ones the I
mean the other one is what you talked
about which is um being
non-operational yeah create a vehicle
that's going to create all your other
vehicles um and and be able to recruit
Talent that's going to be able to put
the pieces together the way I look at it
is like every project needs kind of like
a vision it needs Capital it needs an
operator it needs what you know what are
what does it need okay I'm gonna be able
to create those packages and so that's I
think that's what a lot of them do is
they they get out of I'm gonna go every
day and work on this one business and
toil away like turning the crank myself
and you know that's the the higher
leverage way that they they operate is
is like that yeah exactly yeah I think
that's great and um I think also
billionaires have a different mindset
when it comes to buying expensive
things so you think oh they have so much
money that why would they waste that on
the boat or the plane or the exotic
cars and the truth is um on a lot of
that it's taxes so I have a friend who's
buying a $30 million yacht right now and
he found a way for it to give him a $30
million right off he's going to Charter
it out for a bit but like he receives
more money on taxes than what he's
spending on the yacht and his bank will
finance 80% of the yacht he's only
putting 20% down so it's net net cash
flow positive for him to buy the yacht
ironically and the operational costs are
offset largely by the
charter and you don't think that but it
pays for all his cost and um people do
this with airplanes too I did this with
my airplane I mean I had a bigger write
off from buying the airplane than what I
put down in cash to buy the airplane so
can you give the quick math on uh it
doesn't have your specific plan but just
like just a general math so people that
know like how does the buy a plane work
from a tax perspective yeah well it the
rules are changing but I I closed online
about a year ago and um let's say you
buy a plane it's 5 million bucks and
your Banks willing to finance most of it
so you put a million dollars
down um but you get a $5 million write
off on the plane and it's a year one
write off right that that was a
accelerated bonus depreciation year one
um but now the problem is this year it's
only 80% you could deduct up front next
year at 60% and then 40 and then 20 um
yes it's getting worse and worse but um
but the point is you do get a tax
benefit for buying these assets they are
financed and then also if it enables you
to do more what you want then there's
that like incalculable benefit that you
receive right um seen with excited cars
a lot of people I know who have excited
cars their excited cars are worth more
than what they pay for them so they buy
the car they drive it for a year and
then they sell the car at the same cost
or a higher cost than what they paid for
it because other people can't they want
to have access to that car but they
don't have a relationship with the
manufacturer and they weren't willing to
wait four years on the waiting list to
get that car yeah I was surprised to
learn that that the um there's just a
whole class of really expensive cars
that you basically get to drive for free
it's like putting a deposit down so you
go buy this car uh I don't even know if
this would classify but like our our
friend had a McLaren and he's like yeah
it's great i' driven it you know for a
few years and I'm gonna sell it for
exactly what I bought it for it doesn't
depreciate or it's up you know I'll make
10 20 grand on this thing for the
privilege of driving this around and uh
there's a whole bunch of these like Rich
get richer uh style setups like you know
where if you if once you start to play
It's like a snowball it's like you use
the money to buy something that's going
to make you more efficient and have more
fun or uh you know Do Better Business
and then that also is going to save you
money on taxes today and then it also
going to hold value because it's a rare
asset and so you're going to you know if
you ever sell it you didn't lose
anything just for holding this so you
know you get all these like gains and
they start to accumulate once you start
to get there and I think that's a um a
real advantage and you know some people
who I think are on the other side of
that hate that and they feel like that's
so unfair and unjust uh you know I don't
really give a moral opinion either way
it's just that is what it is and uh you
know you could choose to either um
benefit from that you can choose to
ignore it or you can choose to be upset
about it you have many choices on how
you're going to react to uh you know a
bunch of these things that that come
with you know the the snowball of of of
you know wealth yeah I think I think
it's easy to heat on it but what's cool
is that people could learn about mindset
and how to get there and that's what
you're doing with your pod like you're
very specific about like how to do these
things I've noticed and this was not
available to people five years ago so
yeah um well well it's funny because
like money is this uh taboo thing it's
like we're all supposed to not share
anything we know about money how much we
make what we how we invest what the
returns are what taxes what do you do
with your taxes like everybody plays you
know Clos guarded on that and it's a
real shame because it means it's very
hard to learn uh until that gets cracked
open and somebody starts sharing then
more people start sharing then you start
to learn faster and uh there's this
great Conor McGregor quote where he
talks about like Conor McGregor went
from plumber to highest paid athlete in
the world in a span of five years and
along the way he was higher paid than
any UFC guy ever was faster than anybody
was and there was a lot of guys who had
been paying their dues for 15 years
fighting for you know going out there
and like fighting in a cage match for
$20,000 and then they have to pay for
their flights their hotels the medical
bills and they're left with two grand at
the end of it and they were very bitter
and someone asked him in an interview
they go Connor you know do you ever
think about kind of toning it down
because uh you know there's so many
people that are you know get upset when
you talk about you call your shots you
say how much you're making you wear the
nice watch you wear the nice clothes and
he goes um no that says something about
them not me he goes some people see this
and they take inspiration and that's who
I was I saw people doing things and I
took inspiration and other people see
things and they get bitterness and they
will end up bitter it is not my job to
figure out you know they get to decide
if they're going to go on the bitterness
path or the inspiration path um you know
the right people will get inspired and
uh that actually kind of freed me up in
this podcast to do things that I think
you know ask questions or talk about
things that I think are you're supposed
to downplay everything you're supposed
to not talk about you know certain stuff
um but [__] that you know that doesn't
seem like like I know I I when I was
growing up I couldn't wait to get a
little more information or inspiration
or hear you know that somebody oh this
guy has a private Chef damn that'd be
awesome I don't feel bad that I don't
have one now I now have a new thing that
I've decided that would be really
awesome fun to work for and and a great
like a way to improve quality of life
that I had never even thought about and
um thank you for putting it on my radar
thank you for putting it in my in my uh
you know in front of me that I now
wanted to go go do that I love that yeah
like I think it is difficult to struggle
with the feeling of jealousy and
aspiration and another trick that I'm
not sure if this came from Tony Robbins
or someone else but if you're surrounded
by people who are more successful than
you instead of envying them um maybe you
could interpret it as hey this is a
great sign because this means more
success and more happiness is coming my
way now that I'm able to surround myself
and attract these people into my life
how awesome and um I remember having to
deal with that a lot especially when I
was a upand cominging entrepreneur and I
knew absolutely nothing and I have you
know Drew from drawbox and Sam Altman
coming to speak to me and these like CS
students right like we didn't know
anything and um and the Gap felt very
wide but just having them there to spend
time with us and to say hey we're open
to like just email us if you have any
questions about what it's like to be a
Founder we're going to be there for you
just feeling like all the more
approachable and accessible I think made
it easier for me to focus on the
education instead of the
EnV right that's a that's a great way of
putting it can I ask you one thing
before we go because I know I took too
much of your time sure uh Sam Alman is
now like this extremely interesting
public character um very few people
actually know him sounds like you've had
interactions with him in the past uh can
you give me your impressions or any
story you remember of Sam Alman um
because I remember reading Paul Graham's
essays like 10 years ago where he's like
of the five most impressive people I've
met it's like Bill Gates or whatever you
know Larry and Sergey and Sam Alman you
know and it's like at that's when he was
doing looped and nobody you know there
was no there was no track record he he
sort of was was like it was just very
apparent in meeting him at that time
that this guy's going to go on to do
great things did you get that sense or
um I don't know how much interaction you
had with them yeah I
actually I mean this was probably 13
years ago now but I I had a one-on-one
with Paul RAM and I asked him to share
like who do you think the most um you
know successful people you've ever met
like who will Who will that end up being
30 years from now if we have another one
at one like this and Sam was on the list
I'm not going to share who the others
were on that list um but they're all
also doing extremely well and
um what a question by you by the way
fantastic question yeah and I asked Paul
what are the things in common with these
people what what did by the way he put
me on the list I'm the worst one by far
so I'm embarrassed I felt like I
disappointed him but we'll see that for
another day um and I asked him for like
what are personality traits you find in
these people like how
you know what do you see
and for him it it was less about the
intelligence actually it was not about
the it it goes back to this common theme
we've had throughout the past hour and a
half here on like grit and being willing
to be unconventional and to try
different approaches and to you know to
collect ideas from multiple species and
merge them together to come up with
something even better than what a domain
expert in anyone field would be able to
come up with on their own um and just
like how they show up and what they're
willing to do to meet the right people
was a big part of um what Mak so that's
that also reinforced my wanting to have
this policy of just get on the
plane because that's a trait that
successful people perceive will lead to
you know you being destined for
greatness so to speak like all right
well I don't think I'm destined for
greatness but what if I could
manufacture making other people think
I'm destined for greatness maybe I'll
actually maybe I'll create that reality
somehow yeah eventually you know it
walks like a duck it talks like a duck
hey it became a duck you know by the end
of it actually so so those traits you
said just now sorry to recap was um grit
or resourcefulness like you know the the
willingness to make things happen you
said um uh going into M being being able
to collect ideas from multiple spaces
and and synthesize it so that you
actually might create something more
than any domain than the than the
individual domain experts had been able
to reach you get to a new a new ceiling
um from that that was like the second
thing you said third was uh wanting to
meet the right people ask the right
questions and being willing to go to
certain lengths to to kind of meet them
right that was that was the third one
did I miss one that you said yeah just
to build on that third one it's that how
can you meet
yourself interesting enough at a dinner
party so that they would want to invite
you back to spend more time with them
how do you broaden your field of
knowledge to be able to be an advisor
you know someone that you know a king or
president would want to call upon for
feedback and you know you to Paul youram
sass or this was years ago before you
left for the UK he has a huge library of
books and he's read most of these books
and and he's just fascinated by so many
topics and that also left an impression
on me okay like should just learn about
random things that have nothing to do
with our day-to-day business because
they'll help us with category number
three on that list right right yeah
that's such a good call I went to a
farming conference last year like two
years ago like farmand love and it was
the best conference I had been to in
like five years because i' only been
going to Tech
conferences and you know I'm not
learning anything at these Tech conferen
you know like I'm adding the same
incremental knowledge and it's the same
thoughts and philosophies and same types
of people
in that bubble and there's nothing wrong
with that but like there's definitely
like you want that 20% like total change
up that is um completely at a left field
that's like wow these guys talk about
different things think about different
things have a different perspective live
in a I was in Kansas City right like it
was like uh you know you go to a
different place and you have a totally
different perspective and I literally
started a company while I was there
because I was like piecing together like
two ideas one from the tech world and
one from this like farmer that we had
met and like it you know that was you
know when we created the milk Road and
we even the name milk Road was like
because we're at a freaking farming
conference and there's like a Dairy
Farmer next to us you know like it all
kind of played in to to to having that
if you know we hadn't stirred the pot in
that exact way you know maybe you would
have come up with a different answer
yeah that's super cool that you did that
and I I'm curious
to download from you what is also on
your list of like the next areas you
would want to learn about and um I think
it's actually good exercise for me too
to think about because for me it's been
bio lately but I I would like to brought
in it even more so give an example of
one of the bio companies that you
founded what it you know to give us the
high level of like the problem the
solution you guys are trying to do and
like you know the the rough stage where
it's at yeah the high level is I set up
a holding company uh for biotech uh
Venture creation centered around the
scientist named a Mike Levan if you
search Mike Lon he has a TED Talk he has
a three and a half hour interview with
Lex fredman that I highly recommend you
watch and you will get sucked in because
he's a scientist who studied he got he
got PhD in genetics at Harvard and then
now he's devoted his entire career to
basically proving the fact that genetics
are actually not that relevant in the
whole scheme of things and that it's
this other thing bio electricity that
dictates how long we live um whether or
not we get
cancer um
how our Limbs and body shape forms it's
actually not as much genetics as you
think and genetics is like the hardware
level of biology whereas he says biology
is like the software so you you told me
this you you were like uh we have one
companies astonishing Labs it's about
bioelectricity and I was like what I've
never even heard this word and you said
it in in a really interesting way you go
um you know people think that it's like
genetics is kind of like what your genes
say or your DNA says is kind of like
what ends up manifesting and you're like
turns out it's not that at all which
already I was like oh that's a kind of
narrative violation what is what do you
mean that's all I've ever heard so what
is the answer um and you were like yeah
there's this idea of bioelectricity and
I went and I watched his Ted Talk and he
talks about like you know they're able
to like you know grow an arm on
something's on an animal's back they're
able to like grow a third eye right
they're able to do all these like show
all these amazing like phenotype outputs
without any genetic modification and um
so can you just like explain that a
little bit more about like you know the
kind of the Layman's version of it yeah
well I I'll be honest I don't even fully
understand the science of it but that's
everything you said is correct like if
you manipulate the bi electricity on an
animal um you can create weird outputs
like this so when they saw that a tadle
was growing an eyeball the bi electric
signature of the cells in that area
changed and so the question was oh what
if he created that same bi electric
signature but on another part of the
body what will happen will it grow an
eyeball not only does it grow an eyeball
there but it grows connection to the
spinal cord um and so you don't have to
micromanage biology if you try to change
that through modifying The genome how
would you do that there'd be no way to
do that is the answer and so if you just
think about it logically genetics are
therefore not that end all be all so
anyway I heard of this it blew my mind
and I said this this is brilliant like
is he does he have a commercialization
partner what's the status of it and the
answer is it's still in the lab and
there was no one commercializing this
yet and Paul Allen was funding the whole
lab and then Paul Allen tragically
passed away and then the funding dried
up so he needed money he needed people
to help him make it a real biotech
company so I come in I say I know
nothing about biotech I know a lot of
rich people who would love to fun crazyy
stuff like this and wait wait wait when
you say I came in that means like I cold
emailed him I I called him I I met him
what what did you actually do I met him
through a friend so I had a friend who
was telling me about Mike over lunch and
I thought this is brilliant this is
amazing could we fly out and meet Mike
like next week like I'll literally clear
my calendar and I'll spend a few days
and I will get to know him and figure
out what we could do with this and so I
met Mike spent some time with him and
realized that this is really compelling
and we could do something cool out of it
so um so I hired this guy named Tom Tom
had taken a drug called elonis from Lab
all the way through FDA approval full
approval for $16 million which is
absolutely crazy and the drug world like
normally it takes hundreds of millions
of dollars to get something approved by
the FDA but his drug actually worked it
was putting patients in full remission
the first eight out of nine
patients normally they would be dead
within months with his drug they
were they were going into remission so I
brought him in to go do uh due diligence
on all M Lev's science and figure out a
strategy for turning these into real
biotech companies and so my contribution
was I have 18 I have 12 people who work
with me at my holding company or
whatever you want to call it for me I
don't really think of it as a hold Co or
a venture studio for me it's just an
extension of me where if there's
something I want to manifest in the
world I have a team of brilliant people
will figure out how to help me make that
happen that's amazing and so um so you
do that what is the like uh you know
what's the product or what do you guys
actually
building we are building um several
companies under this hold code so the
first company we created um is called
sju and it's essentially a company that
will help overcome drug
resistance and um how do I make this
more concrete if you're taking uh drugs
for your leukemia or you're taking chemo
drugs it might be effective and work for
well you have lots of drugs that are
effective in work but then one day they
stop working and when they stop working
um unfortunately there are sometimes no
other viable options for the patient
which means they're going to then die
but a month late a month earlier the
drugs were working and they were fine
right so that's one company there's
another company that's
developing um programmable human biobots
and in fact this got you know there's
article about this in nature as of today
and that company is called anthr robots
wow so I'll send you more info on that
if you're curious um that is really cool
I think CNN's going to post their
interview with Mike today about that as
well and so is all your all your bio
stuff under the this lab with Mike Lev
or is there are there other bio bets too
because like you've talked to me about
uh you know at that dinner we were
talking about um I don't know like
pregnancy or something like that and you
said something kind of in passing you're
like yeah like in the next I don't know
10 years uh you know you know you'll
women may not need to birth a baby like
you know you'll be able to just
essentially grow a baby and I was like
what um so like like Avatar how cool
would it be if you could see like a BB
rowing in like a fish tank and all you
have to do is I could swab your mouth
and swab my mouth put it in the machine
and then the be you will start to grow
out of it you know there's just get the
genetic material no sperm and egg no
sperm no egg just raw genetic material
and
uh you know I think that will eventually
be in the future I don't think that's
going to be the next 10 years probably
not even the next 20 years but I I have
random ideas like that this and I think
how cool it it be to find who's doing
that research and and if if I find
people who are then I might support
their work and fund it if not then I'll
have I'll put together my own team and
go try it ourselves and it's likely
going to lose money and fail and not
work but like this is fun F like not
everything has to be for the profit I
know your your whole pod is all about
making money and all the whole shows are
about how to like compound cash flow and
blah blah blah but like what if we could
have fun doing this and by having fun
being Mission oriented you think bigger
you think more Grand about what the
world could become one day and then
you're more likely to end up like Elon
or whatever like that's kind of the
direction I'm going with with my company
here um which I realized is not as sexy
it's not as compelling as saying you
know we're you know making money well
you know maybe it's more sexy I don't
know uh like you know when when Facebook
was uh going public Mark Zuckerberg
wrote this letter to like the potential
shareholders that were going to buy the
stock and it was like I think it was
called The Hacker Way it's a really
great thing I you know I know people are
very skeptical of Zuck but I think a lot
of the stuff he does is is pretty
awesome including this letter that he
wrote and he described the way that they
do things and one of the things he said
is like you know we don't build products
to make money uh you know you know uh we
we don't build products to make great
money we we make money to build great
products like that is the the core of
what we're doing I think Google had said
a similar thing when they went public
and you know I don't think it's one or
the other but there is a first order bit
and second order bit meaning like if the
first order bit is we are trying to fund
bold science that might change
everything um even though it has a high
likelihood of failure even it might take
many years and a lot of money to get
there uh but we think that advancing the
research and ultimately trying to
commercialize the research is the way um
that to me is the version of like we
don't do that to make money we make
money so that we can do that um so I
think in a way it's it's a lot more
attractive and sexier to to to most
people I think if they step back for a
minute a lot of the like money first
comes from the insecurity right like um
just the the sort of wanting wanting
that success wanting that wind under
your belt wanting that safety in the
bank account um you know that's where a
lot of that comes from I don't think
anybody really if they looked at their
life would say I'm so glad I devoted it
to maximizing you know how much money I
made that's a very unlikely scenario I
think a lot of people would actually be
more uh inspired by you know the way
you're doing things now which is like
what's fun what's interesting what gets
me out of bed in the morning that's
exciting that will if done well um can
like you know change change change the
world uh in in the non- cliche way
because stuff you're doing actually is
more change the world than like than you
know the end and arrows of the world
where it's like we're going to change
the world one set of books at a time and
it's like well maybe maybe you're just
doing bookkeeping actually yeah exactly
that's how I felt I I literally had this
nagging feeling in my soul that I was
wasting my capability and I'm sure a lot
of people feel that way awesome well
sounds like we got another couple
conversations to have thank you for
coming on where should people go find
you reach out to you where do you want
to direct people yeah um I mean I'm on
you know my website's ma.com and I've
got a Twitter jesa um JMA official on uh
Instagram and if people want to reach
out you could uh either guess my email
address which is what I've done with
Mark Ben off and everyone else that's a
good filter actually you don't want the
inbound that's easy you want the inbound
of at least you at least able to guess
an email address it's not that l just
likeed I had like I literally emailed
like Mark sales first mark. Benny off M
Benny off uh you know like every per I
could come up with and most of them
bounced and one of them worked
so that's awesome uh thanks for doing
this you're awesome and uh yeah that was
a great episode yeah great great time
hanging out with you thanks for having
[Music]
me